président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur léonard
pour défendre cette institution cette
police républicaine que vous avez salué
dans son quotidien et que nous saluons
tous ici il faut aussi être
particulièrement exigeant
il faut faire en sorte que chaque faute
et il peut y en avoir
chaque accès chaque mot y compris des
expressions racistes fasse l'objet d'une
enquête fasse l'objet d'une décision
fasse l'objet d'une sanction et je suis
sur ce sujet intransigeant parce que et
l'exigence que nous avons vis-à-vis des
policiers qui faudrait c'est garantir
justement la sérénité du travail de
l'ensemble de la police et de la
gendarmerie c'est garantir la défense de
cette police républicaine qui au
quotidien combat combat le racisme
combat l'antisémitisme et s'engage au
quotidien pour défendre l'honneur de la
république
c'est ça qui est essentiel il ne s'agit
pas de faire des amalgames mais il
s'agit effectivement de dénoncer tout
propos ou tout comportement s'il ya
faute
elle doit être sanctionnée et elles sont
sanctionnées le défenseur des droits
il y a quelques jours rang des rapports
sur des fictions plusieurs années mais
policiers incriminés ont fait l'objet
d'une peine d'emprisonnement de quatre
mois il ya quelques semaines à marseille
des policiers ont commis des gestes
inacceptables un comportement
inacceptable selon addition de justice
un des policiers a été condamné à 40
mois d'emprisonnement pour avoir
transporté une personne contrôlée de
force en dehors de la ville de marseille
ces faits là sont inacceptables ils font
l'objet de sanctions
et donc nous devons être vigilants mais
attentif attentif en nous engageant et
je réponds à votre question auprès de la
police et de la gendarmerie depuis 2010
est le budget la police et gendarmerie a
augmenté d'un milliard d'euros
c'est significatif depuis 2010 est nous
avons lancé un programme de recrutement
de dix mille policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires sur tous les services
ceux du renseignement mais c'est aussi
de la police de sécurité du quotidien et
monsieur le sénateur pour clore mon
propos je nous renvoie non pas aux
commentaires
mais la réalité des analyses sérieuses
et récemment l'université du mont blanc
a travaillé sur le rapport entre les
citoyens et la police
48 mille cent trente quatre personnes
ont été interrogées dans ce cadre là et
85,3 % de ses 48 1134
personnes interrogées ont une opinion
très positive et positive de la police
nationale et de la gendarmerie
c'est aussi ça la réalité ce ne sont pas
les commentaires médiatiques et la
réalité elle ne se fait pas sur les
réseaux sociaux
merci